bonjour à tous vous allez pouvoir suivre
dans un instant une audition sur la mise
en oeuvre de l'éco-taxe poids lourd
alors vous le savez le sénat a créé une
commission d' enquête sur les modalités
du montage du contrat qui lie la société
ecomouv à l'état pour la mise en oeuvre
justement de cette écotaxe poids lourds
dans le cadre de ce contrat l'éco taxe
doit rapporter plus d'un milliard
d'euros par an dont 270 millions d'euros
uniquement pour la société ecomouv je
vous propose donc d'écouter dans un
instant l'audition de jean paul faugère
qui était directeur de cabinet de
françois fillon entre 2007 et 2012
allez mes chers collègues nous allons
auditionner maintenant jean paul faugère
qui a été le directeur de cabinet de
monsieur françois fillon premier
ministre
alors cher monsieur nous souhaitons
comprendre quel a été le processus
décisionnel qui a conduit à la mise en
place de l'écotaxe poids lourds et
comment ce projet a été piloté
nous avons auditionné hier monsieur jean
françois carenco qui était le directeur
de cabinet de jean louis borloo
il nous en a indiqué avoir rendu compte
dans votre cabinet tout au long de ce
dossier
donc nos question c'est quel a été le
rôle du premier ministre
comment s'est faite la répartition des
compétences avec les ministères de
l'écologie et du budget la question de
l'inclusion du recouvrement de l'écotaxe
dans le périmètre du contrat de
partenariat est ce que ça fait l'objet
de réflexion particulière au sein du
gouvernement
voilà tout un tas de questions qui
seront complétés bien sûr tout à l'heure
je vous informe que votre audition est
ouverte au public à la presse fait
l'objet d'une captation vidéo ainsi que
d'un compte rendu publié
je vous rappelle que conformément aux
dispositions de l'article 6 leurs
doléances du 17 novembre 1958 relative
au fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires votre édition votre
audition doit se tenir sous serment
je vous rappelle également qu'en cas de
faux témoignages les personnes entendues
sont passibles des peines prévues par
les articles 402
24 13 4 134 14 et 434 15 du code pénal
alors monsieur faugère prêté serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
levé la main droite et dit je le jure je
le jure je me remercie donc je vous
propose donc de nous présenter un petit
exposé liminaire d'une dizaine de
minutes à la suite duquel madame le
rapporteur nos collègues et moi même
nous poserons des questions vous avez la
parole présidente
je vais essayer de vous présenter les
quelques souvenirs personnels que j'ai
de ce dossier sachant que malgré tout je
ne suis pas le plus compétent pour
répondre à l'ensemble des questions sur
ce dossier qui est quand même très très
technique ça j'en ai le souvenir très
précis il est vraiment très technique et
donc je n'en ai vu que les quelques
principaux aspects au fur et à mesure
que le dossier évolue et et le
techniquement le dossier était suivi
davantage à et matignon par le
conseiller en charge du développement
durable et et éventuellement aussi le
conseiller en charge du budget et alors
donc je me référais plus ça à mon
impression à mes souvenirs personnels
plus qu'à quelque chose de très fort
mais les administratifs
même si évidemment je suis à votre
disposition pour répondre aux questions
que vous souhaiteriez me poser et alors
me référant non quand mon expérience
personnelle
permettez moi de remonter un tout petit
peu avant mon arrivée à matignon auprès
du premier ministre parce que je ne peux
pas oublier que j'ai été préfet de la
région alsace
de 2005 à 2007 et ça n'est pas tout à
fait neutre puisque donc c'est le moment
où commencer à s'appliquer la lgv maout
en allemagne j'ai le souvenir très très
précis de la réaction des alsaciens et à
vrai dire c'est une réaction que je
partageais en voyant défiler les camions
étrangers sur les autoroutes alsacienne
et en fait faire du simple transit et ce
transit dans un réseau dont tu y es
gratuit déjà saturé poser un problème et
n'était pas compréhensible pour les
alsaciens et je dirais que ça posait des
tas de questions évidemment un problème
de sécurité routière ça va de soi
c'était très ressenti quand on a des
corridors de camions qui défilent et
qu'on voit les plaques étrangères
ça provoque des réactions on voit aussi
un problème je dirais de qualité de
l'air parce que l'autoroute a35 de qui
traverse strasbourg vraiment est tout
près du coeur de strasbourg
on voit la cathédrale depuis l'autoroute
2 et donc la qualité de l'air les
nuisances sonores
c'était des sujets très très très
perceptible et j'ajoute aussi d'un point
de vue très pratique
là l'état de la chaussée des autoroutes
alsacienne était moyen je dois le dire
et même parfois dégradé et on ne pouvait
pas ne pas établir la relation entre
cette surcharge de trafic est
effectivement ses conséquences
dommageables
d'autant qu'il y avait aucun profit pour
l'économie locale et donc le l'idée
d'une fiscalité dédié est venue très
vite parmi les élus alsaciens
je dois dire qu'il ya eu quelques
hésitations sur le champ pour ma part en
tant que préfet fait valoir qu en droit
il était quand même difficile de ne
taxer que les étrangers ç'aurait été
prévu comme quelque peu provocant à
l'égard des normes de l'union européenne
je voyais aussi que les élus alsaciens
auraient voulu que la totalité du
produit de la taxe éventuellement
envisager viennent au bénéfice des
collectivités locales alsaciennes
là aussi y avoir quelques débats
toujours est il que l'amendement voté à
texte qui est en discussion à la fin de
l'année 2005 à l'initiative des élus
alsaciens et donc porté par monsieur bur
d'écouté a été voté et il s'est
incorporé effectivement à la loi qui a
été votée définitivement en janvier 2006
je me permets d'insister sur cette
espèce de généalogie parce que sa gelée
vécu et c'est évidemment un souvenir qui
était très présent à mon esprit lorsque
je suis arrivée à matignon
je me souviens aussi très bien que dans
toute l'année 2006 qui était donc
l'année qui suivait l'adoption de cette
disposition
l'administration n'a rien fait parce que
pour plein de raisons parce qu'elle
savait pas trop comment ils s'y prendre
pour mettre en oeuvre cette initiative
parlementaire qu'elle n'avait pas
vraiment venir et je dirais que plus
elles creuser le sujet - elle était à
même de
je dirais de l'aborder de manière
approfondie et donc qui a eu un peu de
procrastination changement de
quinquennat lancement du grenelle
immédiatement et le ministère en charge
du développement durable a tout de suite
repris l'idée de la fiscalité écologique
avec une ambiguïté permanente entre
l'objectif de rendement et l'objectif
d'évolution des comportements c'était
une ambiguïté mais à vrai dire du point
de vue du ministère de l'écologie
c'était plutôt le champ de l'évolution
des comportements qui était souhaitée et
ça s'est déclinée en trois idées celle
du bonus malus automobile évidemment est
d'ailleurs que le ministère aurait bien
voulu étendre à tous les ans fin à une
série d'autres domaines surtout les
biens de grande consommation par exemple
mais bon c'est l'automobile qui a
débouché
la deuxième idée c'était la contribution
climat énergie la taxe carbone qui a eu
le devenir que l'on sait et puis c'était
l'écotaxe donc poids lourds donc il y
avait quand même bien une logique
politique et qui a été confortée par les
conclusions du grenelle alors je dois
dire et c'est une évidence que du coup
l'administration il ya vu aussi un
certain intérêt budgétaire car alors que
la sphère alsacienne était une affaire
anecdotique vu de paris malgré tout au
plan national ça commençait à devenir
différents et l'impasse budgétaire dans
laquelle nous nous trouvions sur le
financement des infrastructures
et bien trouvé là une solution
merveilleuse alors dans la dans le stade
de la mise au point du projet je me
souviens très bien qu'il ya eu une
discussion enfin qu'il ya une réflexion
et mais elle a été en fait assez rapide
sur les modalités
car compte tenu de ce que j'ai dit
précédemment c'est à dire d'une certaine
forme de perplexité face à l'ampleur à
la complexité du sujet l'administration
ne s'est pas senti en conciliant fin à
même de prendre en charge un tel projet
et de le mener à bien dans un délai
raisonnable et surtout permettre
d'alimenter le budget de la fist qui
était donc gravement déficitaire donc
compte tenu d'un avis du conseil d'état
qui était favorable en termes juridiques
sur la possibilité d'externaliser là je
n'irai la la perception et la mise en
oeuvre de l'éco-taxe contenu aussi d'une
réflexion opposants d'une part un marché
classique ou plusieurs marchés
classiques parce que ça n'aurait
certainement pas été un marché unique et
un contrat de partenariat
évidemment avec côté un peu novateur
encore de de cette forme juridique bon
cette réflexion a été en fait assez
rapide car la mission d'appui qui devait
formuler une réflexion à une proposition
un avis sur la procédure à retenir a
bien souligné que compte tenu de la
complexité du projet de l'incertitude
sur les choix technologiques de
l'ampleur du système informatique
eh bien oui il était assez naturel de
recourir à cette formule j'avoue qu'il y
avait une contrainte juridique il ya je
crois peser en partie c'est que
nécessairement et il y a une part
d'externalisation dans un système de
cette nature en tout cas c'est la
personne qu'on en avait c'est à dire que
dès lors que la directive eurovignette
va les directives européennes impliquait
que on évite toute entrave à la libre
circulation des marchandises
cela voulait dire nécessairement que le
système utilisé par les poids lourds
devaient être interopérables donc on ne
pouvait pas avoir je dirais un système
purement nationales fabriqué par l'état
et ignorant le reste du monde et donc
l'idée que lille est un acteur privé qui
dirait j'ai un système interne
intéropérables était une idée qui
s'était imposé et j'ajoute que l'idée
aussi que en recourant aux contrats de
partenariat on pouvait avoir un dialogue
compétitif qui permettait à
l'administration d'avoir un vrai
dialogue avec les candidats possibles
pour bien comprendre quelle technologie
allaient être mises en oeuvre et donc
avoir un dialogue d'ingénieur à
ingénieur en quelque sorte pour élaborer
le projet et et choisir vraiment en
connaissance de cause c'était une idée
qui paraissait séduisante surtout que
l'administration soulignait à juste
titre que les expériences précédentes
montré qu'elle était parfois très
difficiles et l'allemagne avaient
démarré très laborieusement et même
d'autriche ou si j'ajoute qu'au delà des
aspects techniques je dois dire que il
était évident pour tout le monde que
l'administration ne savait pas faire
pour de mauvaises raisons peut-être mais
elle n'avait pas les budgets
d'investissement voilà et ses contrats
de partenariat même s'ils ont un coût
c'est évident ça permet d'étaler la
charge
c'est aussi bête que ça et honnêtement
non plus l'administration n'avait pas
les hommes
pour j'irai mener un tel projet donc le
recours à au privé paraissait paraissait
une formule même si bien sûr elle a un
coût j'ajoute que l'aspect maintenant ce
n'était pas non plus négligeable alors
malheureusement alors que bien sûr les
conclusions du grenelle était clair et
le vote qui a suivi était assez infects
intervenus rapidement
malheureusement il faut bien le dire il
ya eu bien des avatars dans la gestion
de ce dossier
d'abord parce que dès lors qu'il
s'agissait bien d'un impôt c'était un
point évidemment capital parce que ce
n'est pas une redevance puisque
l'affectation des sommes et n'est pas
dédié strictement j'irai au réseau qui
génère le prélèvement puisqu'on finances
le rail et le fluvial et c'est donc on
est bien dans un impôt donc l'article 30
cartes imposé à la loi d'être
extrêmement précise et on y est revenu à
plusieurs reprises on a eu en second
lieu bien sûr aussi le problème breton
ça a été un sujet difficile
certains des élus de la majorité d'alors
se sont montrés particulièrement
présents sur le dossier on peut le dire
et il ya eu une négociation un peu à
répétition avec eux puisque s'il ya eu
deux ajustements successifs pour arriver
à un compromis qui était le compromis
final à 40% étant entendu que il fallait
faire comprendre aux élus bretons aussi
que une exonération pure et simple était
tout juste impensable puisqu'il y avait
à prendre une d'égalité devant l'impôt
et que d'autre part il fallait justifier
la variation dans les limites autorisées
par le droit communautaire au titre des
régions périphériques
donc il y avait une contrainte de droit
et puis on a eu le dernier jugeait de
droits traitée en dernier lieu qui est
la répercussion du coup
en pied de facture et c'est vrai qu'il
était un sujet difficile parce que des
contrats déjà conclus et bien si le
transporteur devaient supporter la
charge de l'impôt c'est sûr que ça
déséquilibre est sont sans contrat et
donc il fallait bien recourir à ce
mécanisme législatif
on appelle que ceara tard on a les
avatars contentieux vous le savez le
tribun istrati ensuite infirmée par le
conseil d'état en cassation qui nous a
donné raison
alors vous m'avez posé madame le
président la question du rôle de
matignon bon moi même je peux pas en
témoigner dans le détail parce que je
n'ai pas suivi au jour le jour je le dis
bien mais je sais que des réunions
interministérielles ont eu lieu
régulièrement à matignon sous la
présidence des conseillers au
développement durable auprès du premier
ministre c'était clairement des réunions
de mise en oeuvre d'une décision
politique
actée dans le cadre du grenelle c'était
le manière de mettre bien decker le
ministère du budget notamment la
direction des douanes et le ministère de
l'écologie et du développement durable
est l'objectif des techniciens qui
étaient à l'oeuvre au service je dirais
de l'objectif politique l'objectif
c'était bien de faire en sorte que le
procédure se déroule que se déroule
normalement qu'il n'y ait pas de
fragilité juridique et c'était là là là
je dirais l'obsession je lirai pour une
affaire de cette importance que de
s'assurer que tout était bien en ordre
alors là nous avons eu un sujet
difficile
c'est qu'une rumeur a commencé à courir
mediapart a fait des articles enfin bon
une heure sur le thème mais est-ce qu'il
ya pas d influence sur le choix du
cocontractant influence hors du cadre
légal et sans les venues au point que le
premier a reçu une lettre de la sanef
alertant le premier sur disons le
déroulement de la procédure
je n'en suis plus les termes exacts mais
c'est à peu près ça et alors là il ya eu
une hésitation je dois le dire à
matignon parce que nous n'étions pas en
charge du déroulement et de la gestion
de l'attribution du contrat et il y a
une en principe juridique qui est que il
ya égalité entre les candidats et que le
dialogue compétitif doit placer à
égalité des candidats donc juridiquement
on ne pouvait certainement pas
interférer mais d'un autre côté le doute
qui était en quelque sorte véhiculées
par ces rumeurs avait quand même
contaminer le petit milieu
et c'était une musique désagréable aux
oreilles du premier ministre et donc
pour lever le doute
j'ai choisi de recevoir la sanef pour
écouter ce qu'ils avaient à dire et je
dois constater que ceux qui m'ont dit
mais tu es rien d'autre qu'un plaidoyer
assez classique en faveur de leur
dossier d'ailleurs une bonne facture
bien sûr où je me souviens qu'ils
avaient fait valoir une sorte de
préférence nationale mais qui était
totalement hors jeu et toutes les
manières pour tous ces arguments moi je
les ai renvoyé vers le ministère et vert
ce qui était leur interlocuteur naturel
en tant que candidat l'attribution de ce
contrat
donc on en est resté là mais je tenais à
le préciser parce que c'est le moment où
j'ai tenu un rôle personnel en
interaction avec l'un des candidats
ensuite je me suis assuré que la
procédure était respectée qu'elle était
solide qu'elle était j'irai sans l'ombre
d'un doute
je me souviens avoir demandé au
secrétariat général du gouvernement de
faire d'avoir une appréciation sur
juridique pour donner les meilleures
garanties au premier ministre et puis à
partir de là moi j'ai effectivement
suivi le calendrier
j'avais le sentiment que ce dossier
avait déjà bien trop traîné et donc j'ai
demandé au directeur de cabinet d des
ministres concernés d'aller aux
résultats je souligne que nous avions
fait un plan de financement de la fif
qui comportait une recette de l'écotaxe
dans je ne sais plus si c'était 2011 ou
2012 mais que cette recette allait
manifestement manqué et que c'était
quand même
disons très peu satisfaisant pour le
mois d'autant que des projets concrets
étaient retardés voilà alors je veux
peut-être évoqué d'un mot une question
qui est revenue je vois bien assez
souvent qui est la question du coup je
l'évoqué la formule contrat de
partenariat est certes nominalement plus
coûteuse appartement où le partenaire
privé il a ça marche c'est clair mais
est ce qu'on pouvait dans le cadre
juridique y étaient choisis et qui
paraissait inéluctable compte tenu de ce
que j'ai dit en tout cas
en tout cas c'est ma conviction est ce
qu'on pouvait faire mieux que le
résultat auquel on est arrivé je veux
simplement dire que a personnellement je
ne le pense pas pourquoi pour deux
raisons à titre principal
la première c'est que la comparaison
avec les autres offres mais n'a pas
prouvé que ecomouv était hors sujet et
moins qu'on puisse dire
et surtout ce qui est souvent je crois
évoqué c'est la comparaison avec
l'allemagne et est à cet égard
moi je dis qu a quand même des
différences qui rendent le lait car
finalement assez facile à comprendre
sinon injustifiée 1 le tarif au
kilomètre n'est pas le même donc ça fait
une différence
2 le système français est interopérable
donc système allemand l'est pas 3
l'amortissement des coûts fixes en
allemagne et sur une masse beaucoup plus
grande
ça n'a rien à voir et 4 le réseau que
nous taxons n'a rien à voir avec le
réseau qui est axée en allemagne je veux
dire nous nous taxons des nationales
départementales et quelques autoroutes
gratuites en longueur très limité ça n'a
rien à voir et est donc finalement je
trouve pour le résultat obtenu
est assez est assez positif voilà je
m'arrête là
et pardon d'avoir été si long je me
tiens vaut difficile beaucoup de cet
historique et qui était très précieux
madame le rapporteur oui samson
m'appesantir sur le coup dont
effectivement il est difficile de
comparer comme ça de façon très très
brut
moi je voudrais revenir sur la
définition du périmètre du projet et
donc du périmètre du ppp
certes l'aspect technologique
déploiement etc et est sans doute
important complexe certes les finances
publiques ne permettait pas sans doute
de d'y aller directement et et le pvp
était probablement effectivement puis
une bonne solution mais le fait d'avoir
inclus recouvrement et contrôle de cette
taxe dans le périmètre du ppp
n'at-il pas vraiment modifier la donne
c'est à dire qu'on est arrivé sur un ppp
qui générerait des recettes ce que
l'état n'avait encore jamais fait en
tout cas pas pas ma connaissance est en
tout cas pas dans une telle mesure
donc est-ce qu'on n'a pas la pris le
risque qu on mesure aujourd'hui
simplement
d'avoir des demandes de l'état et
notamment des douanes et des exigences
qui se sont surajoutés les unes aux
autres jusqu'à rendre la complexité
cette fois ci du système tel qu'on a
abouti à tous les retards constatés
qu'on a abouti
à des reports et à une incompréhension
peut-être et aux émeutes où la révolte
qu'on a pu voir contre contre l'écotaxe
est ce que ecomouv à lors des réunions
alertés à un moment l'état sur cette
montée en puissance des ex chance
puisque d'autres candidats l'ont fait en
disant attention vous êtes en train de
demander beaucoup et est ce que vous
êtes en train de me demander en matière
de contrôle du recouvrement de cette
taxe est au delà du raisonnable et au
delà de de l'investissement et la
puissance technologique qui va falloir
mettre en face il ya d'autres solutions
donc est-ce que et como va de son côté
alerté un moment donné l'état sur cette
dérive des exigences notamment des
douanes sur le sujet en fait toutes ces
questions ne sont pas venus à virer à
moi pendant que j'étais à matignon va
faire le dire clairement
voilà peut-être aurait-elle dû mais en
tout cas je ne je n'en ai pas eu
connaissance donc qu'elles ont été
traités en dehors de moi
je donne donc qu'un sentiment personnel
auquel vous m'invitez simplement et donc
qui n'a que cette valeur je pense qu'il
n'est pas illogique que l'état ait
souhaité délégué la totalité du projet
un partenaire parce que j'ai quand même
le sentiment que tout est imbriqué
enfin c'est le sentiment que j'ai à
priori mais c'est une appréciation je
dirais comme ça et donc il faudrait une
analyse technique que je ne peux pas
faire dans l'instant à la question
est-ce que la révolte
enfin je reprends le mot contre
l'écotaxe est lié à tout ça pas du tout
enfin moi j'en ai pas le sentiment ce
sujet mijote quand même depuis un
certain temps ce dont j'ai le sentiment
c'est que c'est finalement une forme
d'hésitation comme sur tous les projets
difficiles qui crée qu'il ya une
coagulation des mécontentements parce
que plus personne ne porte le projet le
pardon c'est une appréciation qui sort
évidemment du champ de mes
responsabilités passées est ce que comme
vous va alerter
moi j'en ai pas connaissance voilà donc
si elle l'a fait c'est pas vie à
matignon et alors est ce que le contrôle
qui a été demandé par les douanes va au
delà du raisonnable
je n'en sais rien mais j'observe une
chose c'est que les douanes n'ont pas
voulu porter ce projet ils ont voulu
clairement que ce soit sous traité voilà
je les observais c'est tout je ne peux
pas dire plus
peut-être qu'ils vous disent le
contraire je n'en sais rien en tout cas
moi c'est le sentiment que j'en ai eu
juste parce que je peux poser la
question des taxes douanières
est-ce qu'on peut pas dire quand même
que l'écotaxe c'est devenu une taxe
douanière
finalement c'est si si si je pars quand
même quelque part oui oui c'est assez
vrai pardon non mais pour pour essayer
toujours sur ce sujet
vous avez parlé de l'allemagne tout à
l'heure en allemagne le taux de
recouvrement demandé de 99 % en france 2
99 75 ça paraît rien mais c est
gigantesque
ce type en termes de contraintes
supplémentaires surtout avec une
contrainte de facturation à tort entre
guillemets parce que c'est peut-être la
facturation sa détection à tort de 1
pour 1 million
donc c'est là où on a la pression vous
me pardonnerez l'expression j'espère
mais qu'on amenait les douanes chez le
père noël et que du coup elles sont
voulu s'offrir entre guillemets un impôt
quasiment à 100% de perception est à
100% de denon erreur donc à 0 %
d'erreurs mais à quel coût et j'enfonce
le coup si vous permettez
est-ce que son histoire du coude quand
même est-ce que peut-être on sait pas du
tout posé la question du coup tu parce
qu'en fait on sale et de toute façon
rapporté d'argent donc c'est quand même
un pvp pour particuliers d'élite dans
mes shows force peut-être le trait mais
c'est pour quand vous mourrez je me
répondiez parce que souvent dans un bébé
pays ça se termine par une subvention
publique déquilibre quelque part un port
ou de déficit d'ailleurs beaucoup rire
au déficit
tandis que là on rase a rapporté un
milliard 700 millions sa vraie milliard
alors est ce que on n'a pas été un peu
un peu d un peu plus négligents sur le
coup parce que tout ça soit allé
rapporter des sous alors
psychologiquement vous n'êtes pas
complètement tort c'est à dire que ce
que j'ai observé c'est que le ministre
en charge et en accord avec nous avait
fixé un objectif qui était on veut à
milliard voilà d'entrée de jeu bon et
d'ailleurs le taux de co km qui avait
été prévu un certain niveau a été
rabaissé pour dire voilà on atteint le
milliard
par contre dire que le coût n'a pas été
pris en considération c'est un peu
provocant peut-être parce que je me
souviens très bien que c'était un des
éléments d'appréciation pour
l'attribution du contrat
donc voilà alors après quel est l apport
des rations de ceux de ce critère par
rapport aux autres moi je ne pourrais
pas vous répondre à une question à
laquelle vous pourrez peut-être pas non
plus répondre puisqu'on n'est pas à huis
clos
mais que j'ai envie de poser quand même
est ce que dans tout ça n'a pas compté
aussi indépendamment de peut-être de
l'envi des douanes donc une fois plus
avoir la peau parfait de se dire et en
plus on va voir une vitrine
technologique européenne voire au delà
pour nos entreprises françaises et donc
ça vaut le coup entre guillemets une
fois plus un peu tant pis pour le coup
tant pis pour la complexité tant pis
pour la difficulté tant pis pour les
retards et puis résultats des tant pis
c'est que c'est dommage je vois les
ressorts psychologiques que vous
développez jeu je suis pas dans la tête
des douanes pardon mais voilà si ces
vitrines technologiques c'est les
douaniers et autres wii autres je joue
bien il ya talent est sans faille à
toutes les entreprises qui sont
impliqués bien sûr à porter je regarde
s'il ya des collègues qui ont demandé la
parole moi moi je vais vous poser une
question sûrement embarrassant donc ont
baissé notre rôle franchement la
question que je me pose c'est pourquoi
avoir sorti ce décret de répercussions à
une date quand même le 6 mai 2012
ah c'est bien tard il me semble assez
bien tard c'était même un peu quand même
non mais ce faux gers et c'est quand
même un peu compliqué de sortir un
excellent simin ont écouté na je vais
défendre quand même parce que ces
périodes un peu équivoque
tous les gouvernements les ont pratiqué
un et je regrette pour ma part en tant
que fonctionnaire j'aurais aimé que les
choses se passent autrement
mais j'observe que parfois les
signatures se débloque dans ces moments
là et
et il peut arriver que un ministre
partant est bien venu finalement rendre
ce service à l'état que finalement
d'endosser la responsabilité et de ne
pas la laisser à son successeur et
finalement je crois que il ya une
certaine voilà il ya une raison à ça et
c'est un dossier bouclé qui a été laissé
à la fin du quinquennat
après la suite est une autre affaire
alors mes chers collègues pas de
questions ces bons joueurs c'est vrai
que c'est tout ce que vous nous avez
rappelé les différentes étapes je trouve
c'était très intéressant de revenir sur
cela manière nous a aidés surtout je
remercie aussi d'avoir confirmé ce qui
nous avait été dit à savoir que ce n'est
pas tant km accès et qui donnait une
recette de 1 milliard mais c'est
vraiment le choix qui avait été fait de
dire on veut milliards oui et après
voulant un milliard on a mis on a mis
tout ça en forme d'accord ça c'est
important parce que vous êtes vous le
confirmer on avait eu cette réponse là
et on a totalement externalisé un risque
vers le privé
alors mes chers collègues je vous trouve
très présent pour la première fois dans
cette commission enquête c'était
extraordinaire
eric doligé ne veux pas parler partement
non madame la présidente non parce que
pour une fois il n'y a pas de
il n'y a pas de remarques sur les ppp
donc je n'ai pas besoin de les défendre
donc voilà donc qui est une de mes 2 mai
marotte
ensuite je pense que ça a été
particulièrement clair sur un certain
nombre de points que l'on n'avait pas
abordé dans d'autres dans d'autres
auditions donc la démonstration a été
clair c'est un éclairage meilhan nouveau
de ce dossier qui est intéressant donc
moi j'ai pas de questions à poser sinon
ce serait plutôt j'ai des questions
qu'ils auraient plutôt des connotations
politiques je pense que c'est pas
nécessaire de le faire aujourd'hui
alors moi je serais tenté de juste après
je donne la parole de ceux que vous
connaissez vous demandez aussi sur la
map un peu votre retour un petit peu sur
la map
bon là il ya eu une évaluation préalable
qui a quand même été très insuffisante
dans le monde tant en tout cas voilà
mais toutes les offres ont été au dessus
on est bien d'accord mais qu'est ce
qu'on pensait comme son rôle de l'ama
parce qu'aujourd'hui
voilà comment comment vous vous le jugez
par cette opération
et puis de sucampo qu'un élève va nous
dire quelque chose aussi
merci la présidente oh oui merci
monsieur faugère d'abord de d'exploser
qui était qui était clair et concis à la
fois ma question sera plus regard de
l'expérience qui s'est déroulé après et
au regard de la mise en oeuvre
si vous deviez aujourd'hui porter un
regard critique sur la sur la procédure
sur le dispositif écotaxe quelles leçons
vous tiriez de de sa mise en oeuvre
telle qu'on peut la connaître
aujourd'hui et c'est toujours facile de
dire encore une fois aujourd'hui mais
est ce que on aurait pu emprunter
d'autres notre chemin de votre point de
vue pour assurer l'intérêt de l'état est
l'intérêt général avec la perception de
cette écotaxe oui donc sur la première
question madame la présidente je suis un
peu mal à l'aise pour être franc je
pense que tout le monde a un tout petit
peu
suivi une courbe d'expérience sur sur
cette affaire on n'avait jamais connu
d'affaires de cette nature avant et la
map
j'irai à perfectionner
petit à petit probablement que les
insuffisances que l'on peut voir à
postériori ben il aurait été bien
difficile de les détecter a priori donc
bon on peut toujours dire que c'est
insuffisant mais je crois qu'aujourd'hui
sans doute la map si elle était
constituée aujourd'hui pour voir tout ça
réagir et sans doute un peu différemment
mais je ne jetterai pas la pierre à ceux
qui la composent et franchement surtout
que ce sont des gens de qualité sur le
cheminement oui je répondrais alors là
pour le coup très clairement j'ai
regretté pour ma part qu'on ne fasse pas
l'étape de la taxe expérimental en
alsace mais je ne vais pas défendu
autres mesures parce que j'étais avec la
casquette de directeur de la mine
prémices d une des potes n'étaient pas
là pour défendre alsace et ça aurait été
mal compris mal perçu je me devais à la
loyauté envers le gouvernement qui avait
choisi un dispositif national et qui en
faisait un objectif politique mais je
crois qu'en termes pratiques
nous avons fait une erreur c'est
qu'après les assauts répond bien à votre
question merci beaucoup monsieur vos
gérant là une actualité du premier
ministre pendant quelques minutes
si vous me permettez comme ça d'
assister aussi à ce débat est en tout
cas merci beaucoup
notre position est très importante pour
nous merci infiniment
voilà vous avez pu suivre donc
l'audition de jean paul faugère dans le
cadre de la commission d' enquête sur la
mise en oeuvre de l'éco-taxe poids
lourds tout de suite la suite de nos
programmes sur public sénat